how you doing Clint I'm good I I'm Clint
family with wired enterprise i'm joined
today by Chris Dancy a director in the
office of CTO at BMC chris is one of the
world's most quantified people we we've
profiled Chris last week he logs
everything he does for work to a google
calendar and he wears multiple sensors
all the time Chris for those who need a
reminder who or who haven't read the
article yet did you give us a brief
overview of what you track and why sure
so I thought a beat there were so many
great questions from the article um I
thought I just share something real
quick too I take probably less than two
minutes to kind of describe what what's
going on here but you know basically you
know for me it kind of started out with
this you know I've always kind of been a
little bit of a quantifier and a lot of
different ways but it wasn't until I
kind of went through this cycle that I
noticed things I came up with this
premise last year after in 2008 I kind
of noticed that nothing I was doing was
being saved online so I thought you know
we're heading to this world where now
gorilla influence what you have access
to personally in a quantified version of
your health which is grown into
something much bigger Polly makes a lot
of sense to start tracking but for that
I had to understand how I used to work
in what work was like in when I started
work and then versus work today and then
the types of tools that I use today to
get work done along with sanctioned
enterprise tools which that's a whole
other topic and then kind of create this
new model for work today so that I could
start to quantify not only my health
which a lot of people are doing but my
activities an information like that one
of the biggest questions I got from the
article and from a lot of people was how
much time does all this take and I'm a
big fan of amber case who I saw it South
by Southwest and then at cyborgcamp last
year
and they introduced me to this concept
of load data a low-friction data
collection so basically depending on
whether it's my home my health anything
else you know I try to use sensors that
collect the data automatically and
quantify it for me like i said this can
be helped this can be worked this can be
entertainment it can be a lot of things
so you know real quick you know it would
take a lot of work for me to scribble
everything down that's something
somebody said you know if you're
recording this all day you're doing any
of that so no I'm not you know
scratching on the wall no I'm not
printing things out manually you know
there's a level of low friction data
collection for me I really all this all
the quantification falls in the four
buckets in archival bucket through
Evernote and that's anything from
putting something on facebook to writing
a Google Doc everything gets written
into a timeline into google calendar I
then also everything gets also put into
a spreadsheet of Google spreadsheet and
then there are new systems like tick
track which I'm playing around with
which do some number crunching for me
for the analytics lot of this comes from
the types of sensors you can get you
know in and around your house today a
lot of people would call this the
Internet of Things you know for health
people that's quantified self so
probably depending on where you're
coming from but you know from the
enterprise standpoint you know I have a
lot of these systems i use Hugh lighting
in my house I have sensors in different
parts of my house you know even my dog
is quantified so he wears you know this
type of collar that tracks his activity
in his motion keeps track of where he is
but for me personally you know these are
the ten areas that I tract health
entertainment environment social media
knowledge work travel opinion content
curation money and spirituality so
everything from meditations to feedback
i leave at restaurants to emails
documents that create two pitchers i
take to the what i listen to one of us
into it how us into it to environmental
things such as noise air quality etc and
then of course all the health things
that people probably aware of with
quantified self movement what i did them
was i I turned those ten areas in to try
to match them to Maslow's hierarchy of
needs so again low friction data
collection thi two aspects of my life
map to Maslow's hierarchy of needs to
kind of create this digital quantified
version of
existence and then this is kind of what
you ran with her than the article where
I can start to make pseudo decisions and
in pseudo analysis about something as
simple as you know the air quality of my
house versus when my when the lady who
comes to cleans for me on Fridays you
know I didn't know until a few months
ago I probably should get out of the
house but then there are a lot of other
you know there are a lot of other data
crunching things and these are all
numbers from some of that data that's
kind of it so that still leaves the
question of how much time does it
actually take you to to kind of deal
with this both from the analysis
standpoint as well as it must take you
at least some time to decide what you're
gonna track how you're going to
implement it that sort of thing yeah
that ok that's pinky that's a much
different question so yes I do i do
carefully decide what what I'm going to
track vs um it does is a kind of return
value on me usually that the quantum you
know the decision for me is you know is
the ability to track it low enough
friction that I can just say yes I'm
gonna track it so you know if I could
walk around all day long and say hey I'm
going to take this this stuffed animal
and you know I want to I don't want to
put a sensor on it I'm on track when I
touch it you know don't ask me why I was
stuffed animal can't believe I just did
that on camera but um if I could you
know if it was old enough friction I
could just put a sensor then I would do
that right because you know there's
probably some element to when i'm in a
meeting with folks and i'm stroking the
stuffed animal under the desk all right
so you know i would want to know that
you know i think i probably spent many
anywhere from an hour to two hours a
week pruning the the collection and the
analytics methods um I probably ponder
for a few more hours a week different
things I could do with the data or
different things I could collect but as
far as manually collecting which seemed
to be most of the questions and the
article I don't write anything down in
any of these systems that people just
saw I just I don't have I don't have
good handwriting and I wouldn't have any
time do anything else so sure well so
what sort of analysis do you do on the
data and like what what have you learned
from it that's been useful well I think
for people
who are you know concerned about their
health I mean one of the things I did
early on with me because I was an
evolution right from 2008 I just wanted
to save my social data you know my
health that I didn't start really
collecting analyzing to last year but
from a health standpoint you know I've
lost 40 pounds and about a year and
that's not really changing that much
about my diet or my activity I'm just
more conscious of my diet now but also
you know because of sensors like a we
mow the time between opening the fridge
door and using the restroom the time
between you know the levels of food that
the types of food I eat you know because
I record that information and then how
they affect something as crazy as what
type of television I'll watch so I've
learned things like I'll eat really
crazy unhealthy foods watching reality
TV and I'll actually try to for some
reason I eat better when i watch
Anderson Cooper now I'm now maybe that's
just a Anderson Cooper I don't know but
uh but other things you know because I
track the ambient noise in the office
I'm in now I've become very aware of
what it's like to be um on a conference
call where I might be a little stressed
out so I use sensors you know to tell me
lower my voice on my voice gets above a
certain decibel or my heart rate gets a
little high I can kind of calm myself
down a little bit we have a question
really ambient noise also really comes
into play because I've also learned
about the types of music I'll listen to
or turn up depending on my mood so it
the one of the first things I've learned
was it was very easy to quantify my mood
from the types of food and the types of
entertainment I was consuming or how
loud i was doing those things from a
work thing you know for my like a work
point of view you know having something
simple as my heart rate being tracked
was really important because you know if
I was you know in the middle of a
meeting at my heart breakout above 80
you know I had to either felt on this
and by the way to aveda now so I must
feel like on the spot I knew you know
kind of calmed
i also noticed i get more work done in
cafes and on airplanes again that's tied
to location and the type of productivity
but then again what's work like so what
does that really mean if it wasn't for
cloud-based systems an open API is this
wouldn't be possible you take something
and I think this is really the profound
part of the article is you take
something as simple as chatter all right
a lot of enterprises have chatter
through Salesforce chatter has a very
open API that talks to zapier there's a
there's just a gaping security hole
there if you put something on chatter
that it can be recorded automatically to
Evernote to a spreadsheet or sent to
facebook except i'm sure salesforce
isn't going to try to lockdown chatter
because they needed to have this open
api so you know to me I you know what
you wrote i thought was really really
important because the idea of what could
be quantified could be seen as really a
way of helping yourself but i think some
people could also see it as a way of
exploiting security holes which you and
I talked about in those types of things
are important to me as someone in IT we
have a question from Google+ has there
ever been a time when the data that you
keep on yourself worked against you well
I keep it still no not yet I'm sure it
will happen but I keep the data on
myself to actually make sure that
doesn't happen you know I I kind of use
this you know mutually assured
destruction mentality when it comes to
my relationship with myself so you know
I have to have the data so that I can do
things to be a better person whether
it's physically mentally spiritually etc
you know a lot of HR departments now
sign their employees up from almost
programs that void trackers and they'll
give you a break in your insurance yet
we would not really you know their
privacy advocates are talking about that
and on one end but then on the other
hand you've got this you know
billion-dollar industry of people buying
all sorts of sensors to help their
health I think there's a there's a safe
place in the middle where you can relate
your health and not the probably
negative way that some people see in
this Orwellian I won't be able to get
health insurance because you know my I'm
above a 79 constant
I get easily agitated those are all
things you don't need quantification oh
you just need to meet me okay uh here's
another question how did all this
tracking actually help you get unops
elite and prepare for the future that
was your headline up and I didn't know
about that headline till I solid so uh I
will you just you did say that you know
you were made redundant after an after
an acquisition and you you felt like you
didn't have a chance one into dozens in
2007 I you know I I was I was with an
organization that was acquired and I was
made redundant and I said to myself do
the skills I have now were they will
they will they will they be employable
in the future and if I look at the last
six years between 2007 and now and I
look at the next six years between 2013
it's 1020 I don't think you can say the
skill sets we had over the past six
years in the 46 will keep anyone
employable so you know how did they make
me how did this tracking make me
employable make me not obsolete it made
me more aware of the pace of technology
which made it easier for me to see
things and what I call a digital-first
manner right so I see data all around me
even though some people would just say
you know a cube and a letter opener you
know I see data and everything now
because of this that helps me in a few
different ways so if I'm sharing content
with my team I try to share it Moi's
that would be easier for their for them
to consume so often I think marketing
and IT professionals we create processes
and procedures to move information but
whether it gets absorbed or used we
really give that a second thought you
know or we blame it on culture or we say
we need better customer experience
measurements and we don't need those
things we need to understand that
there's a really good chance that we're
living in an alternate you know I'm un
reducing this concept of high procedural
you know so if there's a bunch of
digital folks out there who are
consuming information then we need to be
aware of that I think that that's how it
made me not so obsolete I think in a lot
of ways i'm still obsolete but
no I'm just gonna say you know most of
the people I know and I know with the
last five years they quantify their work
and their success at work is measured by
the you know certain number of projects
and but those projects are measured on
emails and calendar appointments I don't
think emails calendar appointments and
Microsoft Office is a skill set that's
going to keep you employable in 2020
when the stuffed animal has sensors on
it saying you're not working or yahoo
saying you've got to come to the office
because we don't know that you are
working obvious obsolescence is really a
nice way of saying you've stopped paying
attention another issue that came up was
one of the services that you mentioned
in the in the interview is memo lane
which compiled Twitter and other social
media into into a centralized location
and then it just so happened that that
service announced that they were
shutting down the day before we ran the
article so that raises some questions
about data portability and sort of
longevity of your of your data so I
thought maybe you could talk about your
sort of your decision-making process
about services that you use and kind of
how you how you plan for that sort of
thing that sort of contingency yes I
started collecting because I was worried
that services wouldn't exist and then
when services did exist I was I didn't
stop collecting I worry about data
portability but you know in the four
areas that I collect this and I use you
know all these cloud-based api's and
systems like zapier and if to write all
this information to all these places so
I can do the analytics on it I worry
about those sorts of things but I make
sure you know I mean I t make sure I
have redundant systems keeping all of
these these things backed up you know I
don't print them out I don't go that far
but but memo Lane is a really
interesting service I think again it
speaks to the power of a digitally
quantified existence you know a lot of
these services there's one called
timehop they they send you emails which
is ironic it's like tying papyrus to
rock and throwing it out of a cave but
they send you emails to remind you two
years ago you were doing this on this
a-and I call that perspective as a
service and I love the concept that we
could as IT professionals or as just
humans we could create systems that give
us a moment of self-reflection because
you never know when that's going to come
or when you're when you're really going
to need it so data port abilities are
important to me thatís Google's done
really good job with data port their
data portability act um you know but I
do worry about other systems you know
Evernote i'm having problems right now
on my my laptop hey evernote can you
call back you know it but I've got those
things in other places so I worry about
it but it doesn't consume me okay here's
another question from Twitter just
wondering if Chris ever feels like a
terminator when they review their quick
when they review their weekly numbers um
I feel like a terminator sometimes
because not not me but I look at other
people like I wish you were upgradeable
ha humanity is getting really difficult
to deal with and for me personally I
mean it helped me become more mindful
but um you know I don't ever feel
machine like although I do wish other
people were okay another question that's
come up is how much data is too much you
know where do you draw the line and
decide I've got I've got too much I
shouldn't be be learning this much well
you know I liken I liken to what i do is
the truman show but except i run the
cameras right so i don't think there is
too much data in a sense that i don't I
think I there might be too much for me
to consume right but I don't think
there's too much for me to collect and
what I do with it is different you know
too much as a term I think when it comes
to data that we're kind of moving into
this age of abundance where you know if
you can save everything why not I mean
again I go back to you know
presentations I've seen where amber case
has talked about how if you printed out
you know all the photos on your phone it
would fill this room you know
that's a tough question i think for i
think for a majority the public right
now in 2013 this would be too much data
i think our children need to grow up in
a world where they understand their
relationship to this data and how it
could be used in systems of digital
influence um you know you in your
article you talked about chatter
analytics and a bunch of other things
these are very real real concerns that i
personally have which is why i say if if
it can be measured someone will measure
it but that someone should be you yeah
it reminds me of you know the the
rolodex was sort of the original social
graph and that you know when there was a
funny scene in i think it was on Mad Men
where somebody got fired and there's
like well I'm taking my rolodex with me
and I mean that's where CRM came from in
the first place was this attempt for for
companies to kind of control that social
graph from theirs from their salespeople
and so as we create I guess you could
call it a performance graph you know of
how you perform at work and I think
you're going to want to have in the
future your own copy of your performance
graph that you can take to another
employer and show them because as you
say if somebody's going to measure it it
should be you and if your company as if
your company is compiling all this
information on who their top performers
are and whatever dimension that is you
want to be able to prove to another
employer you know here's how I did at my
at my other job yeah and that should be
quantifiable internally and externally
into yourself right you know again if we
just look at that says your relationship
to the data that you have whether it's a
document or how far you walked I mean if
you can't quantify that to yourself and
find value in it you'll never be able to
quantify to someone to someone else and
it certainly won't make sense to someone
who's considering hiring you you know I
think if you look at the future of the
enterprise you know systems that create
relationships with data or quantified
enterprise that's the type of thing
that's really important you know
enterprise systems don't get used today
in my opinion ultimately unless
have to because we don't have a
relationship with them you know I think
there's a is that we have to really look
at how dopamine affects how we use these
tools i mean when i log into a lot of
these systems the first thing i looked
at what I look at is how many times did
someone say something how many times
someone do something with something I
created right I don't really care about
me at that point I've detached myself
and we're not creating systems that you
know really affect the dopamine
receptors at work but then again that
would be another level of quantification
and I'm not ready to dig that far
another question from Twitter how well
does this hold up over time especially
as more people move towards working
remotely well people be competing with
locals and peers around the world wow I
think we're competing with locals and
pairs around the world now the problem
is how we define competition is still in
a physical world we think if we say
enough or we create enough that that
somehow makes you know that's that's
quantifiable what's quantifiable and
volume but it's not quantifiable and
impact work in a digital space you know
it's like if you were going to build a
football stadium on the moon you
wouldn't really think about seating or
or or astroturf you know so you know
when you're thinking about a global
workforce and how how it's going to
compete with each other you need to not
focus so much on that the quantity or
even the quality it'sit's contextually
the relationship of that piece of data
to everything house you know again I
know people who love to create lots of
stuff and then o people say I only want
to create the best little thing and I'm
like actually you need both of those but
they need to be in relationship to what
the network you're working in so often
that i'm sure you've seen this Clint
people will share stuff on the network
and you're like I saw that an hour ago
and in your mind you decrement a little
bit like are you not paying attention in
Alexander Bard it was a philosopher you
know he has this concept of the consumer
at and the nitocris t and in the digital
age the consumer at are really this you
know low-level folks who just kind of do
anything for the sake of anything
they're the you know they're the pet you
know they reality TV show people then
chakra see are really the people who are
very cognizant aware of who they are
digitally and connected in a way and
share in such a way and more importantly
consumed in such a way that they're seen
as having value it's really a digital
velvet rope I see happening right now
another question from Twitter how will
this affect growth of poorer countries I
think it's going to do amazing things
for health of poorer countries again you
they you know have to defer to something
I heard amber Hamburg que se at
cyborgcamp you know his systems become
more more neurologically advanced I
don't know if force world civilizations
have the attention to actually
manipulate systems of the future whereas
third world countries they haven't been
distracted all day long may be
distracted by lions and vultures and
also you know just staying alive but
they actually can focus on things that
most people can't you know it still
amazes me when I see someone on a on a
street in new york city or in San
Francisco their phone goes off and they
stop a moving as if no one else exists
in the world and I don't think you'd
have that problem with someone in a
third world nature nation who could
focus their attention so I think they
might have an advantage on on that in
that way okay so we need to wrap up in
about five minutes we have another
question from Twitter real quick how
much time do you spend tracking how much
time you spend tracking no husband I
have a metric for that um like I said
you know it's got to be low friction but
I would put it at about two hours a week
overall if I were to consider high
friction things where I actually have to
type a note like I did something I will
do that I mean I get an email once a day
from a service that says you know 500
days ago you said this and I'll say
something back to it and sometime in the
future it'll come back to me like a
DeLorean 8 88 miles per hour through
outlook right but no more than two hours
but that's two hours spread over seven
days so it's not okay all right well
real quick before we before we wrap up
then I wanted to go back to what you
were saying about the net
ah Chrissy and I I mean I it seems like
I think most people would kind of think
well that that's only really important
if you're in a sort of business where
you want to be a thought leader and that
somebody who is a bookkeeper for a
construction firm or something isn't
going to care about about doing that but
so do you think that this is actually
relevant to you know kind of the larger
white collar work or even you know blue
collar workforce I think it'll probably
hit blue collar before it hits the
secretary you know you look at something
like farming you know farming is one of
the largest technological infrastructure
Xin the world and being able to quantify
what gets done on the farm and how it's
done and by who and in that sort of
thing I think as you know real real
reason to doubt this the concept of an
autocracy or consumer at in 2013 again I
don't think in 2006 we would have said
we'd be talking about somebody who
measured the time between going
literally with sensors go into the
fridge in using the restroom so again if
I just move six years out I'm not going
to try to estimate what's important to
that bookkeeper I think that bookkeeper
is going to be quite different acting
and looking in six years great well
thanks a lot for your time Chris and
thank you Clint but